Google is getting into chips
[Music]
the crunchy kind that you can actually
eat you can probably tell from the
package that they're only available in
Japan and here they're part of the
marketing push for the latest pixel 7
phones from the internet giant designed
to remind us that Google also makes the
other kind of chips the ones made out of
silicon
the pixel has Google's own tensor G2
chip the company's most advanced AI
powered cameras and its Litany of
Internet services from Google Maps and
photos to YouTube and chrome it's hard
to imagine Apple resorting to the potato
chip Ploy but that's because people
already know and love the iPhone whereas
Google is running ads in the US saying
did you know Google makes a phone it
says something about both the ongoing
failure of Google's pixel phones to sell
in big numbers and the company's
opportunity in Japan in the US Apple and
Samsung account for 74 of the market
whereas in Japan Samsung barely scripts
together seven percent that's a missed
opportunity for Google whose Android
operating systems run Samsung handsets
their scope to take chunks out of its
Silicon Valley rival by stealing
business in a way that Samsung has so
far failed to do and if it takes spicy
Savory cheesy gimmicks to help bring
attention to the cause
so be it so how do they taste
not bad but there's a far tastier meal
on offer and Google wants a piece of it
[Music]